Hello and welcome to this course on Datasmith ingestion for Unreal Engine version 5.6.
My name is Alex Coulomb, I am an Unreal Engine authorized instructor, course author, and
also I run the XR Creative Studio Agile Lens immersive design.
In this course we're primarily going to be discussing Datasmith as it pertains to static
mesh ingestion, and in this video we're going to go over the basic course outline and the
agenda we have for this series.
First off we're going to discuss what Datasmith is, how to use it, typical workflows with
DCC tools when you export and then import.
We'll look at various options we have when tessellating CAD surfaces.
When it comes to triangle count we'll discuss different implementations of levels of detail,
nanite, and how to know which one to pick.
In there we'll move on to looking at hierarchies and pivot points as they're set up in your
DCC tool of choice and some considerations for how best to get it from there into Unreal
Engine via Datasmith.
Once your data is in Unreal Engine we'll look at the modeling tools and the static mesh editor
in particular which will allow us to adjust certain things such as pivot points, UV mapping,
etc.
After that we'll look at collisions and how to make sure they're set up appropriately
for our project, and then we'll begin to wrap up with combining objects and looking
at optimization considering such factors as draw calls when to merge actors and use proxy
LODs and other ways that we can start to optimize the project to improve framerate.
Lastly, we'll wrap up with a few future considerations and ways to take this course content further
such as a brief look at Datasmith runtime.
In the next video we'll take a look at our overview of Datasmith.